i have to ask you about season four and
i know that the last time
i asked you for season three details
before it came out you couldn't give
much of a tease i know that's going to
be the case here so instead
i'll approach a season four question the
same way you answered the season three
question here
how does johnny feel at the end of
season three
where where exactly is his head at in
that last moment
it's a complicated feeling for one you
know
he has a daniel just pretty much saved
them
you know to chris was just about to
choke him out um
so i think he's purged at that moment
it's a
there's an emptiness of it of it but as
a he's um
empowered with daniel and it's there's a
good feeling of bearing the hatchet so
at the end of that
but there's also um there's an intensity
they have a common
foe increase now um so the feeling of
that was
um let's was a relief in a sense of
um i have a partner and uh we have the
same
we have the same goal here um but we
have a lot of work to do
and there's still a lot of history
between us and we're both different
and we you know it's like we want this
to work
and here we go
you did it well again you played you
played you played by the rules but you
gave me
a little something to think about yeah
yeah there's a
there's a lot to clean up here with
these kids all coming together and now
we have to march on into uh
into the battle and you know these are
two complex characters
um but who are so similar but so
different
has anything felt different filming
season four
now that you are fully under the netflix
umbrella both
production wise but also maybe just
having a different
vibe on set because your fan base just
grew
exponentially it was already a very
powerful group of people
but the amount of discussion
has just gone from like one level to
through the stratosphere and
even from a fan perspective it has been
so exciting
to see that and to feel that so i can't
even imagine how it changed the vibe on
set
yeah it's just encouraging you know it's
like you know you you
have a good show and and you know you
have a matinee and
the curtains close and people are
applauding and they like it um
and you know you got the evening show
coming now and you got to go out and you
know
you know there's a sense of okay it's
working they like it and
a new kind of energy um of um
you know it feels good feels good when
it's
when it's working than that but as an
actor and my job is
is to stay in the focus stay in the in
the micro of it you can't
you can't be swayed by that you can't be
looking at that you know it's like
you know if you're a baseball player and
you're up a bat you know you can't
you can't look to the left and see who's
in the it was in the stands you got to
keep your eye on the ball
so we're all doing that keeping our
heads tucked the writers are doing their
thing
and we're putting our hearts on our
sleeves and beating our arms up and
i'm shooting big and wide and the
stories are deep
and wide and uh i think we're gonna
deliver a great season four
but it's been it's awesome it's awesome
it's great i'm very happy to i mean why
not you know
why do this if people are gonna like it